of these six remastered multiplayer maps
coming to the master chief collection
we've seen Zanzibar's facelift at
comic-con sanctuaries gameplay reveal at
Gamescom and they even teased us with
the concept art of coagulation aka Blood
Gulch this year at PAX 2014 343 whips
out lockout oh yeah this close encounter
fan fave looks better than ever I mean
look at that nice building structures
get pimped out with more of that
forerunner II architecture and a little
hint of green and how about that view
looks great and remember those empty
canisters where the shoddy was BAM weird
deformed blood abominations which
actually strengthened walkouts backstory
a remote flood research platform where
extreme low temperatures were needed
during an outbreak to delay or slow down
the parasites growth I think the shoddy
hallway gets me the most excited that
Erie miss coating the floor and look
they even put the shoddy up on a stand
that's very nice of them I like that
that's really cool but probably the most
notable change that will affect gameplay
is that elbow walkway near the limbs
which we all remember as the walk of
death classic version had basically no
cover but now well the tip of the elbow
gets a platform with two more walls to
peek out from how about this you can
choose the tip of the ice above the
sniper perch for some sweet hills that's
new other than that the revealed footage
shows the same weapons from the classic
battle rifle shoddy sniper and dual
wielding of gosh that's it i can't wait
let's pull halo 2 classic on xbox lock
oh oh that's right new more xbox live
halo 2 well that's the end of that then
how to pay day I love you guys